was a shooting that has injured nine
people in the middle of celebrations for
the Nuggets NBA championship Victory
thousands of
Timber nuggets one day when the first
ever
again ship and not long after the
celebration shots rang loose sending
nine people to the hospital ten people
total were shot including the gunman at
20th and Market in downtown Denver nine
of those people were taken to the
hospital and three of the victims are in
critical condition the suspect was
arrested and Denver Police say it
appears multiple shots were fired during
an altercation involving several people
now again one suspect was arrested and
the Denver Police Department tell us
that this is an ongoing and complex
situation